- Where the hell did it go?
Oh I see it. Yes, good.
- [Babin] Alright, next one from Benny.
- Yeah, motherfuckers.
(upbeat music)
- What's up, vlog, gonna
be a wacky day here.
I don't know how much you're
gonna be able to film.
Not a whole lot. Just
feels like it's the story
of Babin's life
- [Babin] I've got a few questions from...
(traffic drowns out speech)
- Alright, let's do a couple
questions right here right now.
Let me just give you guys a
sense of what I'm doing, too.
Just to bring a little value.
Like, I'm just trying to bring
a little more value to the vlog.
Got a one-on one meeting
right now with somebody pretty
important in business.
Can't give anything here.
Just a classic hour-meeting where I'm --
You know so much of what...
I noticed a long time ago,
somebody posts something
about the vlog and they're like,
"You don't do anything." You know?
Like, "What the fuck?
You just travel around
and have meetings..."
And like, "Fuck you."
I'm just laughing about this next meeting.
It's going to be an hour
meeting. It's gonna be a meeting.
It's going to be relationship-building.
It's power brokering. It's
just, who do you think is smart?
Who do you think is
doing interesting things?
Actually I think we're
going to be able to show
a little bit of this meeting,
which is nice because now
I gave her a huge dap.
So it's just like, who do think is smart?
Who do you think is
doing interesting stuff?
And that is worth your hour
because you might be able to
provide that person value.
And then that's in the
ethos and karma's practical.
For me, there is no
bigger strategy on Earth,
than to provide as much value
as possible to everybody,
and then there's an extra kicker of,
if you can provide value to
the three to four percent
of the "winners" in society,
without any expectation.
Because you gotta understand
if somebody's a three
to four percent winner in society,
their whole life, as
somebody who lives that life,
and likes to think that
he's getting into that zone.
Every single meeting is somebody
asking you for something.
So the off-speed pitch,
the complete curve ball,
if I could spend more time
having meetings with people
who are playing at the
top three to four percent
of the world in their
craft and genres that I'm
interested in, and the entire
meeting is me providing value
for them, well then I would
be set for the next five
decades of my career.
So that's that. That's a
nice little rant on that.
Then I have a meeting at Apple, shh.
And then I'm ging to
VaynerMedia, L.A., to meet with
a bunch of one-on-ones
and catch up with people,
and then I've got a meeting with shh,
and then, I've got a meeting with shh.
One meeting is with some
other tastemakers another one
is with a potential client.
None of it can be shown,
so let's get into the Q&A.
- [Babin] All right, the
first one from Leenda Dee.
- Hey, Leenda.
- [Babin] "When you know
your day is going to be crazy
how do you mentallyl
prepare yourself for it?"
- Every day of my life is crazy, and busy.
And if you mean crazy like --
That's not fair. All my days
are crazy by regular standards,
but above and beyond for me,
like everybody's got their baseline.
To me, I use perspective when
I've gotta do things that
I'm not looking forward to.
Like going to the dentist,
is for me, like, crazy.
You know, things like
that. So, just perspective.
Like, "I could be terminally
ill", is kind of where I go
somewhere, "people I care
about could be terminally ill".
Just putting things in perspective.
I also think that you've made your bed.
You've signed up for this.
I hate when people dwell or
complain about shit when it's
the infrastructure they've
created for themselves.
You've picked that job,
you've decided to start this
startup, you signed with
that manager, you've decided
to create this business,
you've decided to put yourself out there.
I'm a big fan of I signed
up for it so I gotta eat it.
- [Babin] Nice. Next one from Laura Elisa.
"What are your thoughts on
content marketing, and also
what marketing strategy
for major businesses do you
see as most successful
considering the generation
and current time?"
- I'm just telling the
person I'm 10 minutes late.
One more time. Name?
- [Babin] Laura. What are
your thoughts on content
marketing, and basically
what's the best marketing
strategy for major businesses
to do in this generation?
- I think content is
the variable of success,
so I think it's oxygen.
If you're not producing
content, you're not relevant.
Now, "content" can be
broken down a lot of ways.
A lot of people, a lot of businesses,
back to your question, are
making content in the form
of commercials, and marketing.
I think that's a bad
idea for the most part.
I think there's a new age of
content that can be produced,
that has far more
storytelling, compelling...
Don't make a commercial,
make a movie trailer to sell your product.
That kind of thinking.
I think every business needs to think more
like a media company.
AKA, Volvo needs to think
more like ESPN, Conde Nast,
CBS News, Steven Spielberg,
than they need to think
about making a Volvo commercial.
What do I think about it?
I think, A, it's the cost
of entry of success in
today's environment.
If your make it in the form
of content and information-
entertainment, not in
the form of a commercial
or a sales pitch, that is
the biggest differentiator,
and that's how think about it.
You should start a podcast
for a million dollars instead
of spending a million
dollars in radio ads,
and that's where big
businesses are getting caught.
(upbeat music)
- [Ara] Hi!
- Sorry I'm late.
- [Ara] Don't worry about
it. So good to see you.
Welcome to Venice.
- Thank you.
Hi there, ah...
- [Babin] Babin, nice to meet you.
- [Ara] Come on in.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
Listen, you've got by back
phone, I'm happy to help.
- [Ara] I know, thank you.
- [Gary] Alright, nice to
meet you man, take care.
That was cool, right?
- [Babin] So I found three that are
kind of weird, but practical.
The first one, from Christopher:
- By the way vlog, I'm
so pumped up about this.
I literally think this
could become the vlog.
Like, "Backseat Answers".
Alright go ahead.
- [Babin] Christopher. Is
there any strategy for farmers
other than direct
marketing meat and produce?
My family raises commodities
like corn, soybeans, etc.
Margins suck and it feels
pointless for current ROI
of such a huge investment.
- Love this nerdy question.
Big shoutout to all the
farmers that have been such
a foundation of this incredible country.
But the world evolves, right?
Farming, once the technology
industry of our society,
no longer to your point brother.
What's his name again?
- [Babin] Christopher.
- Chris. Christopher. I get it.
Here's what I would say. If
I were the son of a farmer --
Was that my headpiece? What was that?
- - If I was in that game --
God, was that my headpiece?
- Sounded like it.
- [Babin] Yeah.
- Let's leave this in the vlog.
I think it's really funny. Anyway, um...
Bro if I was in that
business I would start small
and I would start a brand.
If you're producing corn...
If you're producing corn,
or carrots, or cabbage,
start a very small direct
consumer brand in that space.
Make the capital investment
to those kind of business models.
I think that there is an
incredible opportunity for you
in starting a very small
direct consumer brand.
Call it Christopher's Corn,
like Bobby Babin's Beef Jerky,
and away you go.
I think that's the strategy.
Start a direct consumer
packaged goods foods brand.
Start it very small, make
1,000 bucks the first year,
I don't care, eventually you
could become Jolly Green Giant
if you do it right.
You're making this stuff.
The margin is with the people
who know how to market it
and sell it. Figure out how
to build those capabilities.
Start small: farm stands,
and Shopify and Amazon,
and take it from there.
Where the hell did it go?
Oh I see it. Yes, good.
- [Babin] All right, next one, from Benny.
- Yeah, motherfuckers.
- [Babin] (laughs) Alright, Benny.
Can you ask Gary, any
advice for people who
do door-to-door sales?
Specifically, home security sales.
- Alright, first of all,
Babin, you are evolving
into a great teammate.
These are great niche questions
that don't normally get answered.
This is the foundation of
Backseat Answers With Gary Vee.
(whispering) Backseat Answers, BSA.
(bell sound effect)
I think there's a lot of
thoughts I have on door-to-door
salesmen, and I think doing
your homework is very important.
For example, if your know that your going
to be in Edison, NJ., and
that's where you sell,
I would go to Twitter,
and search Edison, NJ,
and see that people are talking about.
If somebody says, "Sam Darnold, yay!"
like I would be when I was in Edison, NJ,
then you roll up and you make
a Darnold reference, or you
deliver a Sam Darnold T-shirt
or something of that nature.
I think people can use
Twitter search in the radius
that they're selling door-to-door.
Some people may think it's creepy.
But you start with, doo-doo-doo,
"Hey, I'm a new wave
door-to-door salesman. I use
Twitter to make it awesome.
I saw that you're a Jets fan, here's a
little Sam Darnold T-shirt.
Now, your home security sucks."
That's just wild, that's different.
You may get the mom who answers
the door and she doesn't
know what you're talking
about with the Twitter thing.
Look, technology has
allowed us to know more
about the people we're selling to.
I think in door-to-door sales,
the people who win the most have humility.
If I was door-to-door
selling today, I would knock,
and I would say, look,
I know you don't want
me here. You're busy.
Very simply I think you're overpaying
for your home security. That
would be literally my pitch.
I think door-to-door does too much sizzle
and not enough steak. Sizzle like "Hey!"
I would go reverse,
brother, like humility,
like I know you don't
want me here, you're busy,
I appreciate you even opening the door,
you're overpaying for
you home security system.
Fuck technology, that's just door-to-door
salesman fucking concepts.
More humility, less hyperbole.
- [Babin] Last one. This guy
runs a snake breeding business.
If you ran that business
how would you market it?
- I would make a ton of content.
If you're snake breeding you
fucking won in today's world.
Visual content for days, just incredible.
Also I would run heavy,
heavy ads on Youtube preroll
based on Google searching,
so people searching snakes,
snake breeding, then they
go watch a Gary Vee video
but the first 30 seconds
is a snake breeding video
and you're into that.
Preroll Youtube based on
search query capabilities
on Youtube is one of the incredible
ad products in the world,
and I highly recommend
that you do that if
you're a snake breeder.
(upbeat music)
If I bought the company tomorrow
and had the bucket of money
for two videos, one anthem
video, the way you wanted it,
one the way I wanted it, a one-week --
(audio censored)
- - or wherever else, and social
media ads to drive business,
and the payers that we've
allocated to the influencers.
If they all started at
the starting point that
we are at now, I would probably
take 50 cents on the dollar
from all the other buckets and
put it into giving out more
- - (audio censored) --
to post on Instagram.
Because I genuinely believe
that would sell the most
and build the most amount of brand.
Give me the actual
number. I will personally
Wednesday night, my
team, put all these ideas
over a four hour period, line
by line -- (audio censored) --
for two pop ups -- (audio censored) --
when he comes through.
Literally line for line.
Like -- (audio censored)
-- for podcast integration,
because I'll hit up -- (audio
censored) -- I will literally,
line by line break down
the most comprehensive
culture media plan you've ever seen.
I just want to make sure
that I have every dollar,
and that when I give it
to those were the dollars
and then all you'll have
to do is say yes or no,
and then we can fucking roll.
Hey
- Hi
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Woman] Good. How are you?
- [Gary] Good. Hey.
- [Man] Hey.
Hey
- Hi
- [Gary] 'Sup Jiggy?
- [Jiggy] Oh hey. What up?
Hi
- Yo
- Hey Babin.
- Cool, I'm gonna start,
because I don't wanna
hold up too much time.
Thanks for getting together, L.A.,
I have a couple announcements
that I wanna walk through
and then, if you wanna
just hang for 10 minutes
and answer any questions anybody may have
and any other things going on.
So, we have some pretty
exciting announcements --
(speech cuts out and upbeat music swells)